she's healthier than me ever since I can
remember I have made a conscious effort
in my life to have a incredibly clean
and healthy diet I am vegan and I tend
not to eat too much gluten eating food
is equal to happiness so I really need
to focus on eating what I like a lot of
junk food usually my mom was really into
health and said something I grew up with
I'm sure that when I start eating
healthy it'll probably you know do
something magical I mean if it doesn't
I'm never gonna eat healthy so I think
for me it's gonna be hard mentally but
physically it's gonna be harder for you
literally all my favorite okay pizza oh
you put in parenthesis I can usually eat
the whole pizza no vegetables on it so I
guess I mean yo ho pizza oh so breakfast
smoothie I like smoothies blueberries
kala banana wait Chris Potter what sweet
bro
wheatgrass is um it's a guy's so I'm
eating rest yeah I think one out of ten
I'll do maybe like eight so Saturday
morning I went to get the smoothie for
my breakfast smoothie and then I got a
wheatgrass shot because they had it
she's gonna happen we trash shot and you
like it's like not good at all it's like
warm grass I did the whole Saturday
morning cartoon thing in bed with my
bees it's just really really sugary I
don't know if I can eat a whole bowl of
this let's go good
so it's 11:50
and I finished a smoothie while I was
driving and I am so hungry I'm used to
very carb heavy breakfast I was getting
kind of hungry so I went to yoga
Saturday afternoon I was really tired
during class it's as if the sugar from
the cereal just rushed to my brain and
all I want to do is go get a giant green
juice to cleanse the sugar out of my
system Sky's drinking something healthy
what's your drinking I cheated okay but
after dinner I made up for it I ate a
whole bunch of Doritos I meet so many of
these you're amazing Wow smoothie time
oh it's good I thought was senti it's
like really bad so that's really good I
even went hiking with my dog and I was
like feeling good I was like yeah I feel
healthy and I have energy the only sucky
part was like after I came back home I
was super hungry and you know and tired
but I have to cook again I really failed
I fell hard I'm just getting a minute
I should have been better I should have
stuck to the experiment more but I felt
the effects and Sunday night dinner I
went through the Burger King dry field
you are the last person I would have mad
to accept this challenge because of how
often we discuss health and how often I
see you doing like push-ups in our
backyard hi can I have a small fries and
a coke
like I feel if anyone saw me doing this
would just ruin my image I have a
burning desire to eat the rest of this
I'm not crazy massive craving noodles
salad kale I want other stuff I want
like chicken wings and I want burger it
Pizza other stuff to go with it I would
prefer it with just like normal noodles
I think that would be really really good
but this is a healthy alternative I'm
really glad I did this challenge it was
really like I learned a lot I learned
how to cook a little bit and I learned
about a lot of other ingredients that I
didn't know about like I realized
throughout this experience that the food
that I eat is so much a part of my
identity and not having it I feel like
I'm not myself
[Music]
sweet chili Doritos are the bomb it's
all good to say about that
[Music]